.
VERY HARD TO FIND POLITICIANS
WHO ARE CAPABLE OF BEING WILLING
TO DO THAT, THE GOVERNOR OF
TEXAS IS ONE OF THEM, HAPPY TO
JOIN HIM TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
YOU ARE THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR WHERE THIS HAPPEN, TELL
US YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> TUCKER, SINCE I WAS ELECTED
BACK WITH GREG ABBOTT BACK IN
2014, THIS IS NOW THE FOURTH
MAJOR MASS SHOOTING THAT WE HAVE
HAD.
SEVERAL IN THE CHURCH, AND HAD
THE WALMART IN EL PASO, AND THEN
FOUR YEARS AGO, FOUR YEARS AGO
AND ONE WEEK WE HAD THE SHOOTING
AT SANTA FE WHERE WE LOST EIGHT
STUDENTS AND TWO TEACHERS.
AND I WILL TELL YOU, TUCKER THAT
I HAVE BEEN TO A LOT OF FUNERALS
AND A LOT OF SERVICE, A LOT OF
HOSPITALS.
NOTHING COMPARES TO WHAT BILL
JUST SAID ABOUT THE LOSS OF A
CHILD, AND I THINK THAT --
THIS IS PURE EVIL.
IT IMPACTS THE WHOLE NATION.
EVERY PARENT, EVERY GRANDPARENT
THAT HAS A CHILD ENVISIONS WHAT
THEY WOULD FEEL IF IT HAPPENS TO
THEM.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT GOES TO
THE CORE OF OUR SOUL.
ALL OF US.
AND I HOPE THAT THE PRESIDENT
TRIES TO UNITE, NOT TO BITE US
ON THIS.
BECAUSE WE AS A NATION WILL
ALWAYS REMEMBER THIS.
THESE CHILDREN AT THE SCHOOL AS
ADULTS ONE DAY WILL NEVER FORGET
IT.
THESE TEACHERS, THIS COMMUNITY
OF 16,000, THE SCHOOL SYSTEM
ONLY HAD 4,000 STUDENTS IN THE
WHOLE SYSTEM, SO THESE ARE
CRIMES THAT GET TO THE CORE OF
WHO WE ARE AS PEOPLE, AND I
THINK AS PEOPLE WE HAVE TO LOOK
INTERNALLY AND HOW DO WE GET
HERE?
THIS WAS AN EVIL ACT, THERE IS A
LOT THAT WE WILL LEARN AND IS
GOING TO INVOLVE IN THE DAYS AND
THE TIMES A WEEK WITH THIS
SHOOTER, WE HAVE TO UNIFY IN
PRAYER AND FAITH AND WHO ARE WE?
WHEN I GREW UP IN MOST OF THE
PEOPLE WATCHING GREW UP AND YOU,
WE DID NOT HAVE THE SITUATIONS.
WE DID NOT HAVE MASS SHOOTERS IN
OUR SCHOOLS IN THIS EVIL, SO WE
REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT US AS A
PEOPLE IN A COUNTRY, BECAUSE WE
CAN DO A LOT OF THINGS.
IN TEXAS HAS DONE A LOT OF
THINGS AFTER THE SEVENTH DAY
SHOOTING.
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE TO DO MORE AND
HARDEN THE TARGETS SO THAT THEY
CAN HARDLY ENTER EXCEPT THROUGH
ONE ENTRANCE, MAYBE THAT WOULD
HELP AND STOP SOMEONE.
BUT IT'S BIGGER THAN THAT.
WE ARE AT A CORE SOCIETY.
WE ARE SOCIETY THAT IS AT EACH
OTHER'S THROATS ALL THE TIME.
AND WE ARE BETTER THAN THIS AS A
NATION.
I WANT TO PRAISE THE TEACHERS,
BECAUSE I GUARANTEE YOU, EAT WE
DON'T KNOW THE STORIES YET, BUT
ALL OF THOSE TEACHERS ARE HEROIC
TODAY.
I GUARANTEE YOU EVERYONE DID
WHAT THEY DID IN SANTA FE AND
TOOK THEIR KIDS AND THEY
SHELTERED THEM IN PLACE AND THEY
TOOK THEM TO PROTECT THEIR LIVES
AND TEACHER SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
HAVE TO DO THAT.
>> Tucker: I BELIEVE THAT,
ANYONE WITH KIDS KNOWS THAT
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHERS ARE
THE BEST.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THE PRAYER
PART OF THIS.
SO POLITICIANS ALWAYS SAY OUR
PRAYERS ARE WITH THESE PEOPLE
AND THEN YOU HEAR PEOPLE PUSH
BACK AND SAY, PRAYERS ON AND
OFF, THEY DON'T WORK.
WHEN YOU SAY YOUR PRAYERS ARE
WITH PEOPLE, YOU SEEM TO MEAN
IT, TELL US WHY YOU THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO PRAY IN A MOMENT
LIKE THIS?
>> FIRST OF OFF, I AM A
CHRISTIAN, JESUS CHRIST IS MY
SAVIOR AND THAT IS HOPE, AND
HOPE IN THE BIBLE SAYS HOPE IN
THE BIBLE SAYS THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE EXPECT THAT
WILL HAPPEN, AND THAT'S TO BE
REJOINED WITH OUR LOVED ONES.
THAT'S THE HOPE THAT WE HAVE.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU, TUCKER, THAT
WHEN I HAVE BEEN THROUGH ALL OF
THESE MOMENTS AND TRIBULATIONS
OVER THE YEARS THE ONE THING I
SEE IS PEOPLE STANDING ON THE
ROCK OF THEIR FAITH, THESE
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING THROUGH
THIS NOW COME THESE PARENTS AND
GRANDPARENTS, THEY HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE GOING TO
WALK WITH THEM.
GREG ABBOTT, MYSELF, THAT THE
DEMOCRATS, WE ARE GOING TO WALK
WITH THEM.
WHERE THEY LIVE, THEY ARE WITH
THIS PEOPLE.